looks like the storms are gone for now
outside though the winds are picking up
we've seen them breezy throughout much
of the afternoon they continue to blow
we'll see
those winds calm down a little for
tonight but the storms are off towards
the east and we remain
dry for now 106 our official high for
the day today
puts us a digit above normal 116 is a
record
on this date back in 1998 remember we
saw these temperatures
this temperature last week at this time
and
numbers now are finally near normal 84
overnight for the low so
numbers outside at the shower we start
off in spring valley 103 for you
107 for centennial hills and sky canyon
currently 108 for north las vegas 107
sunrise matter 105 for whitney ranch
henderson just a digit above that
mountain's edge at 103.
same for rhodes ranch elsewhere 103 also
for indian springs 117
death valley still hot for you 109
in laflin at this hour so the storms
continue here there's a look at
flagstaff sedona
right here there's the grand canyon
getting nailed with those storms
that westerly flow is giving us that dry
flow right now that's why we remain dry
and the dew points
and the humidity has dropped but lots of
storms to continue in tucson that's
where the flash flood watches are
the high just to the southwest of us
will start to pivot its way up towards
us now
during monsoon season when that high
sets up shop to the east of us in the
four corners region
that opens up the gates and the doors to
the monsoon giving us some thunderstorms
and that's what's going to happen
right where it needs to be pulls up that
moisture on that clockwise flow
up towards our area and that's going to
begin on sunday
and last through through the week
tomorrow looks like we'll stay on the
dry side
getting very close though to some
thunderstorm activity on the far
eastern portions of the county but most
of it will be focused
the attention of the storms will be
focused on utah and arizona again
for tomorrow before that all changes on
sunday
here's the forecast 86 overnight clear
and warm we'll still see some breezes
overnight 107 for tomorrow hot and sunny
still above average but we should remain
dry for now
the highs tomorrow 104 for summerlin not
much of a change where we saw today 105
for mountain's edge
109 sunrise matter in north las vegas
should come in 106 degrees outside the
valley 110 for laughlin
104 for prompt along with boulder city
so here's your
eight day forecast after tomorrow we
have hit and miss
storms even scattered storms from sunday
and beyond look at that through next
week
temperatures will remain near normal but
of course the humidity goes up
that's your most accurate forecast back
up ready